I'm already live on TikTok with a pretty
solid guest so far. He's a Muslim and so
we're just talking about Jesus being the
Messiah and really the the
substantiation that Islam has for saying
that Jesus is the Messiah and what that
actually means, the implications of
that. So, you guys are actually jumping
in right when we're in the meat of a
good conversation. All right, go ahead,
bro. Uh, what did you ask me? I was
asking who these these people are you're
quoting from. You know, Matthew, Mark,
the disciples.
Yes, the disciples. Did Did they really
write that? Yes, 100%. So, you're So,
you're saying that Mark is the one that
actually wrote Mark? Mark wrote Mark.
Luke wrote R Luke. Matthew wrote
Matthew. John wrote John. Can you Can
you prove that? Well, I that's another
subject. I can prove that. Sure. I can
give you the evidences for that. But
first, what we're talking about is your
substantiation of Jesus being the
Messiah or the the claims that you know
that was made against him by the Jews.
this this information you're getting it
from is from the Bible that you're
doubting. You doubt the Bible. You doubt
the authorship and all this yet you're
pulling information from it. You get
what I'm saying? Yeah. Well, the Quran
does it it does affirm the Bible, but
doesn't affirm it completely. We as
Muslims, we believe that there's truth.
There's still truth in the Bible, but we
still believe that there's falsehood in
the Bible at the same time. And so, but
you I I understand your position. That's
circular. Whatever agrees with the Quran
is good. whatever doesn't agree with the
Quran is bad, right? I I I know the
logic. Well, however, we are talking on
something that the Quran doesn't speak
on. The Quran doesn't tell you what
Messiah means or why Jesus is the
Messiah, how he is the Messiah. It
doesn't speak on this. It just says he
is the Messiah. My question to you, my
question to you is when Jesus came to
them and said, "Guys, I am the Messiah."
What reason would they have to believe
him? He was given he he did miracles in
front of them. Okay. So, is doing
miracles does doing miracles make you
the Messiah? I guess. Yeah. If if you're
given miracles by if you're given, you
know, no, because ability to do
miracles, you believe that prophets did
miracles, right? You believe Mo Moses
performed miracles. You believe Muhammad
performed miracles, right? But they're
not messiahs. They're not the Messiah.
Yeah. So, then that's not enough.
Performing the miracles isn't what makes
him the Messiah. What makes him the
Messiah? What reason would they have to
believe him? just they wouldn't really
have any reason to believe him. Now,
just to I want to make sure I catch
everybody up. Our friend's point here is
that Jesus what makes Jesus the Messiah
is that he's going to come back and you
know unal alive the antichrist. Yeah, if
my camera's looking at you, I don't know
what to do with that. I I don't know
what to do. Uh I'm not the camera guy. I
need to bring life in to come fix this.
But his position is Jesus is the Messiah
because he's going to come back in
Islam. he's going to come back and fight
the Antichrist and defeat him. And so
I'm just saying and he's like, "What's
the problem with that being what makes
him the Messiah?" Well, the problem is
is that prior to him coming back and
killing the Antichrist, there's no
reason to believe that he's the Messiah.
Yet, the Jews here are getting punished
for rejecting him as the Messiah in the
in the Quran. Allah condemns them for
rejecting Jesus as the Messiah. But my
question is, what reason would they have
to accept him as the Messiah in the
first place if it won't be proven until
generations later when he comes and
kills the Antichrist? So it matters,
right? So if if if the proof doesn't
come until way later, then Allah is
actually unjust for condemning the Jews
for rejecting him as Messiah because
they did he didn't give them any proofs
for it. You get you get my point? I
mean, yeah, he he did give them proof
that he was the Messiah. That's what I'm
asking for. What were those proofs? He
healed. He healed the sick in front of
them and they rejected. Working
miracles, we see other prophets did
miracles. So working miracles doesn't
work as well. Huh? Yeah. The other
prophets, they did miracles as well.
Yeah. So it doesn't but they're not the
Messiah. So working miracles is not what
identifies the Messiah. So what what
could I could I ask you a question?
Yeah. Okay. Let's let's say for example,
you were sick and I told you I'm the
Messiah. I'm going to heal you and
miraculously I heal you and there's a
bunch of people watching. Would you
would would you believe that I was the
Messiah because I healed you
miraculously? I I would believe that you
had some miraculous power to you. I
wouldn't be sure if you were the Messiah
or not. I would have to check because So
the Jews they the Jews they did know
that Jesus he he did have power. Yeah,
but that does that make him the Messiah?
Of course it does because if he's
claiming to be the Messiah and he's
performing miracles because he told them
I'm the Messiah. Okay. How do you know?
And he came and told them, "Oh Israel,
your Lord is one." He came to teach to
teach. So could could Moses or somebody
else claimed to be the Messiah for
splitting the sea or doing whatever they
did? Solomon for talking to the ants?
Could he have said, "I'm the Messiah,
guys. Look, I'm talking to the ants."
No, because they never claimed to be the
Messiah. But if they if they did, could
they rightly claim to be the Messiah
because they've done miracle working
power? No. Because God didn't appoint
them to be the Messiah. There it is. So,
do you see how working miracles isn't
what designates someone as being the
Messiah? So, God appoints Jesus as being
the Messiah. What makes him the Messiah?
It's not the miracle working. What is
it? What is it? Like when he came to the
Jews and he told them, you know, I'm I'm
the Messiah. Again, he did perform
miracles in front of them and he tried
to show them a proof pro proof that he
was, but they still they still rejected
it. I don't know. You know what was the
proof? What's the problem? What was the
proof? We're still here. What was the
proof? Because performing a miracle,
dude. Come on. Let's not go in circles.
Let's not go in circles. We already We
already acknowledged that performing
miracles is not what identifies you as
Messiah. Can we agree? Yeah. But can the
Messiah still do miracles? The Messiah
can still do miracles. That's true. But
miracles, but not every miracle worker
is the Messiah. So, we say that Jesus
performs miracles. Okay, that's cool.
How do you What makes him the Messiah,
though? Cuz God chose him cho chose him
to be the Messiah. How do you know? Cuz
that's what our book tells us. Why
should a Jew believe that? Why should
anyone Why should anyone believe? Why?
When Jesus You didn't have the Quran.
You didn't have the Quran. All the Jews
had was the Torah and the writings of
the prophets. Torah. The Torah and the
Psalms. Yeah. So that's all they got.
They don't have a Quran that comes later
and says, "Yes, Jesus actually Jesus
specifically is the Messiah." They all
they have is the Tanakh, the Torah, the
Psalms, the writings of the prophets. So
what was it that they would use to
confirm whether or not Jesus is the
Messiah? There is nothing that talks
about Jesus. And I don't, in my opinion,
I don't even think Jesus he's even
mentioned in in the Torah. So then why
on God's green earth would they believe
him? There's no proof. There's no
confirmation. You performed. You came to
us. You came to us. Whoopde-doo. Many
came to us. So what? Oh, you performed a
little miracle. So what? So did Moses.
So did uh Elijah and Elisha. Yeah. But
their miracles, their miracles were
different to the miracles of Jesus.
Elijah raised the dead. Yeah. With Yeah.
By by the permission of God. So So they
perform miracles. Yeah. So they have so
as as a Muslim you have no way to
substantiate that Jesus is the Messiah.
You have nothing. You have nothing to
give. Just a we believe. What do you
mean by substantiate? What do you mean
by substantiate? Like elaborate. So you
would need something like for so the
Messiah has requirements. It has check
boxes, right? Yeah. And you have to
check these boxes off in order to
qualify to be the Messiah. Not every
Tom, Dick, and Harry can come and say,
"Hey guys, I'm the Messiah." And
actually be the Messiah. You have to
check some boxes. And I'm asking you,
what are those boxes that need to be
checked that identify someone as
Messiah? And the answer is, you don't
know. Could you give me a second so I
could check and I'll get back to you?
Yep. 100%. You're back. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. In the Old Testament in Isaiah, it
says, "A virgin will give birth to a son
and we will call him Emanuel." And what
does that tell you? That that that
refers to Jesus. So that would be a
prophecy of Jesus. Boom. Absolutely. Now
you are you understanding now? So we see
here that the Messiah, one of the
requirements is that he needs to be born
of a virgin, right? Yeah. Good. And so
when Jesus is born of a virgin, that's a
box that's checked. Requirement met,
right? Fulfillment. Fulfillment of
prophecy. Now, here's the thing, though.
There's something that's important
because you acknowledge that this is a
prophecy about Jesus which is beautiful.
Obvious it's obvious the virgin birth,
right? Yeah. Now, it says that they uh
they shall call his name Emmanuel,
right? Yeah. Now, Emmanuel, this is a
it's a name called Hebrew word. Yep.
It's a Hebrew word. Do you Does it say
what that Hebrew word means? No. Uh but
I I've heard this verse before. It's
it's a charact it's it's a
characteristic. Mhm. And what does it
mean? Uh if you you don't know off the
top of your head, but check look look I
don't know what the top look it up real
quick. Look up what God what uh what
Emmanuel means really quick. God with
us. Boom. So according to the messianic
prophecy of the virgin birth, God is
going to be the one who comes and is
born of a virgin. The Messiah is God
with us. So when you're saying that
Jesus is the Messiah, you don't know it,
but you're saying that he's God who's
with us. That's who you're identifying
him to be. You see the problem? Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. I see. I see issue there. So
it's this is this is the conundrum. This
is the dilemma that Islam is in. This is
another Islamic. Okay. But if but you
could still interpret the word God with
us with Jesus coming to spread the word
of God. You could still interpret it
that way. No, because it doesn't say
that. It doesn't say that he's going to
bring he's coming. God's message is with
us. Doesn't say that. It says God with
us. The person being identified God with
us. You know, it's very straightforward
and clear. And then it also makes sense
on top of what Jesus would claim about
himself, right? He says things like, "I
give eternal life. No one can snatch
them out of my hand." He says things
like, "I am the resurrection and the
life." He says things like, "You're from
below, but I come from above. I came
down from heaven." These are things that
he says in light of if the Messiah is
God. Having this understanding now, what
Jesus says about himself makes sense.
Because only a lunatic, a lying lunatic
will make these claims, will lie about
this stuff. But Jesus, who speaks truth
with no deceit, no sin in his mouth,
comes and says, "I'm the resurrection
and the life. I came down from heaven. I
am the bread from heaven that gives
eternal life and food. Eat of me and you
will not never hunger. Drink of me and
you will never thirst." No human and no
creature can talk like this. These will
be blasphemous claims if Jesus is not
God. I I see your point. But you know my
my my issue is my my issue is how do how
do you know that these are the words of
Jesus? How do you know the gospels you
have today were actually written by the
disciples of Jesus? Well, I could take
this as from a Muslim perspective cuz
I'm talking to a Muslim. You have no
room to doubt that these are the words
of Jesus because the Quran says that
that which was there in the possessions
of the in the possession of the Jews and
the Christians is true and the Quran
confirms it in the seventh century. What
they had in the seventh century which
they were using Matthew, Mark, Luke and
John, the writings of Paul, you know,
Old Testament, all that. They were using
all of that. They had it in their
possession. And the Quran says, "I
confirm that what you have is true and
I'm in line with it. I'm just an added
on." Are you are you talking about the
verse or if if you if you're in doubt,
go talk to the people that read the
scriptures before you? Nope, not talking
about that. But that's a really good
verse. But this verse specifically I'm
talking about is there's a few verses
that say this, but um chapter 2:41 is
one of them. Chapter
2:41 says that says to believe in what
we have sent down confirming that which
is already with you. That's chapter
2:41. So the Quran came down confirming
the scripture they have in their
possession. The scripture they have in
their possession is true. So as a
Muslim, you can't doubt what I have. You
can't reject it cuz the Quran affirms
it. Yeah. But the Quran also says that
Jesus is he's he's just a man. He's just
he's just a messenger of God and he is
not God to that contradict. Hey, you're
right. So, this is where we find
ourselves. Islamic Central, we find
ourselves in a dilemma. The Quran
confirms and attests to the truth of the
scriptures that the Christians and Jews
have with them. However, those
scriptures that the Quran says is true
say that the Messiah is God, say that
Jesus is God and he's the son of God,
the father and so on and so forth and he
was crucified. But the Quran in other
places rejects those things. It says
Jesus is not God. Jesus wasn't
crucified. Jesus is not the son. Right?
Allah has no children. He doesn't beg
nor is he begotten.
So we have the Quran confirming a book
that it contradicts at the same time.
That's the Islamic dilemma. So this
shows that the Quran is false because
it's confirming a book that it says is
true. So if the Bible is true, then the
Quran is false for contradicting it. If
the Bible is false, then the Quran is
still false for saying that a false book
is true. Either way you go, the Quran's
in trouble. Yeah. But the Quran doesn't
doesn't confirm the Bible 100%. Just it
it has a general confirmation for it.
The Quran doesn't doesn't say that every
single word every single word of the you
know the Bible is the word of God. Okay?
So I'm going to this is what I'm going
to do. I'm going to give you a couple of
verses where it says that what they have
what they have is true. Period. It
doesn't say that a piece of what they
have. It doesn't say part of what they
have. It says that what they have in
their possession is true. I'm going show
you that. And then I'mma also show you
where Allah sets a general rule that he
hates and I mean hates when people
cherrypick his scriptures where he says
that where where some people say this
part of the scripture is good, the other
part is bad. I'm going to show you
verbatim explicitly that Allah hates
when people do that. I'm going to do
that for you. I'm going to show you
those two things. In return on your
side, I want you to show me the
opposite. I want you but to the same
level. The same level that I'm showing
you clear, explicit, you know, right in
our face, right on the page words. I
want you to show me the opposite. That
the Quran doesn't confirm all of what
they have, just only part. and that only
part of the scripture is true while
other parts are is false. Okay, I want
you to show me that. All right, so let
me start first. Chapter 2:41, it says,
"And believe in what we have sent down
confirming that which is already with
you." So according to the Quran, what is
already with the Jews and Christians is
true. It confirms it. Not part of it,
not some of it, but what they have
period in general. Okay, you with me so
far? Yeah. All right. Now, here's
another one. We're going to just stay in
chapter 2. By the way, guys, stay tuned
for the Friday stream. We're going to be
back Friday. Big stream. David Wood, me,
Giant DLC, try to get Chris and Speakers
Corner. I'm going see if IP want to
join, too. We're going to be having
Muslims come and challenge us on chapter
2 alone on whether or not the scriptures
are corrupted. Chapter 2. We're going to
just be using chapter 2. That's it.
Okay. So, staying in chapter 2, verse
85. You got a computer with you, right?
You said no. Check verse 85 in chapter 2
of the Quran. What's the verse again?
Chapter 2. Verse 85. Nice, nice, nice,
man. We got 2,000 people watching on
YouTube. Make sure everybody hit the
like button, guys. Smash that like
button. Everybody, I know it's easy to
forget, but you support the stream by
hitting the like button. All right, as
we get up, do you believe in some of the
scripture and reject the rest? Boom.
Now, what happens? Keep reading. Is
there any reward for those who believe
in some of the scripture and reject? Oh,
sorry. Is there any reward for those who
among other other than disgrace in this
worldly life and being subjected to
harsh harshment punishment on the day of
judgment for Allah is never unaware of
what you do. So you see how Allah hates
a person who picks and chooses from his
scriptures what they choose to believe.
Yeah. uh saying a part of it is good, a
part of it is not good, a part of it is
he hates it. He says the person who does
that will be disgraced in this life and
will have a severe punishment in the
next. So I laid this out to you. The
Quran confirms the scriptures that the
Jews and Christians have in their
possession. And he hates
cherrypickers. You can never say part of
his scripture is corrupted and part of
it is not. You have to believe in it
all. You can't pick and choose. Make
sense? Yeah. But the Quran also says
that that that that you know that in
jail and the Torah are corrupted though.
That's what it says. It doesn't.
However, let me grant this. Okay. It
says they change the word of God with
their hand and they tell people there's
the word of God. Well, let's go with
that cuz it doesn't say that. But let me
grant it to you just for this because
that's in chapter 2 as well. So in
chapter 2 what we have if and if I'm
granting your pos your position that
chapter 279 which is the verse that
you're referring to says that the
scriptures have been corrupted right
that's chapter that's verse 79 and then
but when we go before verse 79 verse 41
the first one that I quoted says that
the scriptures that they have is true we
get to 79 it says but the scriptures are
corrupted and then we get to verse 85
that says do you believe in some of the
scripture while rejecting other parts It
does that make sense that Allah in one
place same chapter but earlier will say
their scriptures are true and then a few
verses later would say their scriptures
are corrupted and then a few verses
later say you better not pick and choose
out of those scriptures you better
believe in it all. Does that make sense?
Yeah, it does make sense.
I'm Let me explain. Stop it. I'm
listening. Go ahead. Cuz that verse that
verse says woe to those that change the
word of God with their hand. Right.
That's what that verse says. So it's
referring Let me let me clarify. Let me
let me fix it for you. It says, "Woe to
those who write the book with their own
hands, claiming that it's from God,
seeking a small price." Yeah. And all
the scholars agree that it's talking
about the Torah and the Injil. Wait,
hold on. But not all the scholars agree
that the Torah and the jail are
textually corrupted. Only some do. Yeah.
Whichever one say that it's uh, you
know, corrupted, I I follow them. I
know. I follow the ones that say it's
not. Okay. Yeah. But the Quran is it is
it is talk it does it does affirm the
Bible and the injil and the Torah but
doesn't affirm it you know 100%. Okay.
This is what I need you to do. I need
you to show me that. Show me where it
says that it only confirms part of the
scripture and show me that Allah and
this is no disrespect. I'm not being
disrespectful at all. All right. This is
just the conclusion that we're coming to
based on your position. You're basically
telling me that Allah is a terrible
communicator. man that he's just
flabbing at the mouth and in one place
he says the scriptures is true in the
next breath he says they're corrupted
and then in the next breath he says
don't pick and choose out of these
scriptures all of it's good you better
believe it all like that is confusion to
say the least what I want you to do show
me where the Quran cuz I showed you
where the Quran confirms all the
scripture and says that you can't pick
and choose I showed you that verbatim so
show me in the Quran the same equal
value can you Give me verses where it
says that one that the Quran only
confirms part of the scripture or some
of the scripture, not all of it. Show me
a verse that says that. Yeah. The the
Quran doesn't say that, but the taps
says. Okay. All right. Now, so the Quran
I thank you for your honesty, bro. So,
the Quran doesn't say that. The taps,
the explanations, the commentary say
that. And by the way, that's not all
there. That's some of them. while others
say that they're unaltered. They are
unchanged because no one can change
Allah's words. So you have a split
within the scholarship of Islam among
the explanations. You have a split view
on this. They're not it's not all um
what's it called? What's it called when
everybody a it's not a consensus. Yeah.
Okay. So, and and it's actually
fascinating that the ones who hold the
position that I'm advocating for that
they're not textually corrupted and that
they're all all of it is confirmed and
so on and so forth, they use the Quran
and the Sunnah for their proof. The ones
who hold your position have no evidence.
They have none. Just their opinions.
They have nothing from the Quran and
nothing from the Hadith. But when when
you talk about the word of God, the word
of God, yes, it can't be corrupted, but
that's the physical word of God. The
Bible and the the Torah, it's it's
literally just pen and paper. Someone
can change that. Okay. But I need you to
the physical word of God cannot be
changed. But you can change words on pen
and paper. I hear you. My my what I want
you to consider is the argument that
we're laying out and think about the
implications like the result of what
you're saying. Allah says that he
confirms what is in their possession.
Right. Yeah. He then later says that he
does not like when people choose part of
their scripture to believe in and part
of his scripture not to believe in. He
hates that. That's what you're saying
the Quran does. You're saying that the
Quran picks and chooses what part of
Allah's scripture is good and what part
of Allah's scripture is not good when he
literally says he hates when people do
that. How does that make sense? You see
what I'm saying? Yeah, I I I I
understand the point you're trying to
make. So, you got to drop this position,
bro. It's not a good position to hold.
You got to drop it. Change course
because you're making Allah look like a
crazy liar. I can't believe I'm sitting
here defending Allah right now. I'm
defending the Quran. But the issue is
that the scripture that that you guys
have today says that Jesus is crucified
and Jesus is God. And the Quran firmly
denies that. So, that you know that that
that's where we say, you know, that the
Bible's been corrupted, it's been
shamed. people, this is their
interpretation. Or you look at the
logical explanation that the Quran is
confirming a book that it contradicts.
And so therefore, the Quran is
inconsistent. It's false. It says the
Bible's true, but then contradicts the
Bible. If the Bible's true and the Quran
contradicts the Bible like it says it
does and it says it is, then the Quran
is false for contradicting something
that's true. If the scripture, if the
Bible's not true, it's false, then the
Quran is false for saying that a false
book is true. There's no way out. Either
way you go, the Quran is false. Bible
good, Quran false. Bible bad, Quran
still false for saying Bible good. You
see the dilemma? I I yeah, I I see I see
the point you're trying to make. Well,
to be honest, I'm not I'm not really
educated on those points. I will do my
own research and I and I will I'll come
back and uh speak to you about it. Sure,
man. Look, do me this favor. Like, when
you're looking into this, try to find
all the verses that you think um talk
about this the corruption of the
previous scriptures. Bring right write
those verses down. Even get their
interpretations. Come back to me. We'll
talk about those. Okay. Yeah, for sure.
Have a good day. All right. You too,
bro. Cool, cool, cool. I like that, man.
I like him.